haha on chinese state media that's going
well coronavirus conquered by medical
care and fist bumps for others inside
Wuhan the experience is very different
mr. pong father fell ill at the end of
January
his family begged the Wuhan authorities
for help after falling into a coma
unattended for three days his father
died pictured here with his son
mr. pong doesn't know what happened to
his body the lockdown in Wuhan is still
in place residents confined to their
flats with guards at the compound Maya
is inside with her mother and a young
daughter
a child has not left their flat for more
than five weeks now she doesn't resent
the lockdown
just how long it took for authorities to
put it in place they were totally me I
asked them they were telling me that
this is not good but they then they
didn't wanted to tell me more about it
so I'm thinking well this is definitely
something serious why didn't they want
to tell you more about that I assume I
could only guess was because maybe
because they cannot say anything about
it in
China sometimes it's very hard to talk
about this kind of crisis and some
people have been completely trapped by
the lockdown mr. Lee drove a thousand
kilometers to visit his grandmother
faloona new year and then the ban was
put in place his streets has been
physically barricaded his family are not
taking baths for fear of catching a cold
and being sent to a quarantine Center on
state media the scale of the struggle
against coronavirus is clear it is the
small difficult details the details that
constitute people's lives that are
missing tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing